В Антальї стає тепліше. Тут поволі розпочинається сезон відпочинку.
Деякі готелі завершують останні приготування, а деякі вже відчинили свої двері.
Після двох років пандемії нині місцевому туристичному бізнесу загрожує ще одна криза:
війна Росії проти України. "Ми звикли до кризових ситуацій",
- запевняють представники галузі.
Туреччина має близько 40 років досвіду в туризмі.
За ці 40 років нам довелося мати справу з багатьма кризами.
Тому ми називаємо туристичну індустрію
галуззю з сильною імунною системою.
Щорічно до Туреччини приїжджає близько 6 мільйонів
відпочивальників з Росії та України. Скільки їх буде цього року?
Наразі невідомо.
Через невизначеність, викликану війною в Україні, кількість
російськомовних гостей падає. Найбільшою проблемою є
насправді авіарейси. У попередні роки до Антальї чартерними рейсами
приїжджали гості з різних міст Росії та України.
Тепер їх немає. Рішення щодо цього ще шукають.
Цього сезону галузь дуже сильно потерпає через війну в Україні.
Зазвичай ми вже були б повністю заповнені на липень і серпень,
але цього року нам не вистачає замовлень з Росії,
майже нема бронювань на цей період.
Раніше за сезон приїжджало від 5 до 9 тисяч туристів на добу.
Цього року туроператори приймали у травні по 400-500 гостей на день.
Але і ця цифра не додає впевненості.
Натомість побільшало замовлень з Європи.
Британці та німці бронюють відпочинок у Туреччині дедалі частіше.
Є ознаки надії. Європейський ринок виявляє дедалі більше інтересу.
Зараз багато туристів приїжджає з Великобританії.
Наші німецькомовні гіди також повідомляють про збільшення замовлень.
Це нас дуже тішить.
Деякі готелі вже встигли зайняти більшу частину своїх місць.
Вони вдало розпочали сезон.
Кількість гостей з Росії та України в попередні роки наразі важко
визначити. Зараз мета – досягнути щонайменше 2 мільйонів туристів.
Ми не знаємо, чи приїдуть українці цього року. І чи взагалі приїдуть.
Але зараз розбираємося з Росією.
Turkish Airlines відновила польоти. Найближчими днями російська
авіакомпанія "Аерофлот", турецький "Пегас" та інші, мабуть,
полетять знову. Тому ми припускаємо, що кількість гостей з Росії
становитиме 1,5-2 мільйони. Але зараз нічого не можна знати напевно.
Деякі українці уже в Антальї. Але не як туристи -
тут вони рятуються від війни. Росіяни ж їдуть у відпустку.
Тут живе наш друг. Моя родина живе в Харкові.
Я приїхала з братом і з нашими сусідами.
- Які у вас плани на майбутнє?
Я не знаю. Це дуже складне питання. Ми не знаємо.
Я приїхала з Росії, місто Санкт-Петербург,
на відпочинок до Туреччини. Чому приїхала?
Тому що зараз не дуже гарне становище у Росії, у нас у країні.
Щоб трохи перезавантажити свій внутрішній стан.
Наразі тільки відкрита Туреччина, тому ми і приїхали сюди.
Я приїхала з Москви, десь місяць тому.
Ми хотіли відкрити банківський рахунок в Туреччині,
щоб мати можливість використовувати гроші за межами Росії.
Я з Росії, з Санкт-Петербурга. Приїхав після того, як почалася війна.
У Росії працював в іноземній компанії,
з оплатою могли виникнути труднощі. Наш офіс перенесли в Туреччину.
Ми приїхали з Білорусі. Чому ми тут?
Тому що зараз у нашій країні дуже складна ситуація.
Тому ми вирішили на деякий час переїхати до Туреччини.
Ми повернемось, можливо, коли війна закінчиться, чи коли ситуація стабілізується.
Це основна причина, чому ми тут.
Це дуже жахливо, всі війни погані.
Мені не подобається ситуація між Росією і Україною,
нашою країною та Україною. Я хочу миру між Україною і Росією
і щоб Білорусь і Україна жили в мирі.
Я думаю, що майже всі білоруси хочуть миру.
Ми не підтримуємо ані Лукашенка, ані Путіна. Ми на боці українців.
Кількість туристів дуже важлива для місцевих торговців.
Одні дуже хвилюються, інші поки не переймаються.
Криза між Україною та Росією нас не торкається безпосередньо.
Ми торговці посеред міста, у Калєічі.
Це давня частина. Тому російсько-українська війна
нас не зачіпає безпосередньо.
Наш ресторан - це невеликий ресторан у домашньому стилі.
По нас це не сильно вдарить, але у нас часто були приємні
російські та українські гості. Якщо вони не приїдуть, ми понесемо втрати.
А от якщо вони приїдуть, звичайно, у нас більше заробітку.
Економічні санкції в останні тижні призвели до проблем з оплатою для росіян.
Кредитні картки російських банків більше не діють за кордоном.
Я більше не можу користуватися своїми російськими кредитними
картками. Мені довелося зробити нову кредитку в Туреччині.
У росіян своя платіжна система. Вона називається "МИР",
тут зазвичай здійснюють операції через неї.
Оскільки вони приїжджають через російських туроператорів і вже там розрахувалися,
організатори потім перераховують гроші готелям. Тому проблем немає.
Минулого місяця наші гості лише тут дізналися, що їхні кредитні картки
більше не працюють. Їм доводилося оплачувати рахунки різними способами.
Деякі робили перекази через Western Union, інші навіть розраховувалися
криптовалютами.
Тож тією чи іншою мірою війна Росії проти України
таки впливає на всю туристичну галузь Туреччини.
Замінити туристів з Росії і України гостями з інших країн -
нині найбільший виклик.